ecco in questo video ragazzi vedrete
cose strane molto strana quella tutti
ragazzi e bambini di questo video sono
qua vj eccoci siamo in un nuovo blog
prima di cominciare ragazzi come al
solito ripartire con la sua arte la
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da chiara che ha fatto elettorali
massicci sguardo sexy
cioè mi rispecchia proprio in pieno
cazzo vabbè comunque ragazzi passando le
news
allora avrà pochissimo dovrei tornare a
casa mia a quella normale quella con lo
sfondo classico di sempre e poi mi di
trasferire un pochettino più avanti
comunque per ora sappiate che ci sarà
questo cambiamento sento questi ragazzi
vorrei passare agli eventi della
settimana perché questa settimana c'è
botto di roba vedrete venuta questa
settimana ragazzi ho fatto una capatina
a londra e ho fatto un paio di riprese
il giro giusto perché meritavano enjoy
ragazzi sono sotto london eye e dei
giganteschi london eye qualche roba
l'attrazione più grande che io abbia mai
visto in tutta la mia vita dopo il mio
pene dove neanche tipo i poster dei one
direction che sono tutti i quali membri
da quando election anche c'è anche
questo che quello nuovo
perché ha perso no non lo so
l'orologio qualche parte ma oggi no
come sull'orologio sguardo sul telefono
una roba che palle non lo so il governo
pure il telefono scarico allora chiesto
cioè non è che ti ho chiesto chi sta
credo sia una roba difficile in questo
momento non ti sto rispondere non so
dove guardare lo chiedi a qualcuno si
esce
[Musica]
i ragazzi sulle tegole sono a secco di
vite migliore sono eventi o non davo
chiesta una roba difficile c'era chi
parte vi state chiedendo come sia
possibile che mi abbiano riconosciuto a
londra non ne ho la più pallida idea
cioè ragazzi non phishing sono ragazzi
della terra che ci hanno scritto non
phishing però non si può pescare perché
c'è una foresta quindi che cazzo no
perché avevo giustamente di prendere un
canna da pesca iniziano a pescare roba
nei pesca signora
no non pescare i ragazzi ci canta ti
devo chiedere qualcosa island a nord
ok this man is a box in aeroporto
l'unica cosa che trovavo in giro era la
free gj la classica precisa e cioè sulla
panchina qui oh mio dio
ma allora una cazzo di pisa ciechi di
chi è questa roba ragazzi mi perseguita
la troverò nel letto ma guarda come
incazzata quindi ragazzi detto questo
passiamo alle favi domande che sono
alquanto strane vorrei partire ragazzi
con la prima favi domanda che questa
cavi files assolutamente la ceretta
ma sei serio [ __ ]
va bene ragazzi allora ho preso ma
perché questa è una cena io non ho idea
di come si faccia questa cosa c'è
scritto di metterla nel microonde
ma come nel microonde siccome io non c'è
un posto dove mettere le microonde dove
metterlo qua sulla sedia e ci mette
conto di che cazzo mi fate fare ogni
volta lei è la fiera che merda perché si
prevede che la mia gamba è fatta così
c'è una foresta amazzonica la sotto come
cazzo faccio a farmi la ceretta chi
guarda ecco è pronto che roba di marco
ho sempre sognato di avere un futuro
destino
grazie a parigi ma perché lo stiamo
facendo fuori c'è perché c'era la luce e
poi 16 url e si sente tutta milano
aspetta carino se gli fa mai
dai vieni detta felice il dottore ma che
schifo che schifo dai 9 animale dove ho
sconfitto però mai male quando ai traumi
fare uno sì ma quando lo strappo aspetta
a casa letta quelli farla raffreddare un
attimo saluta tua mamma ma cosa cazzo
all'assoluto mia mamma stiamo tagliando
faccio la chiamo da te lo prometto volta
che saluta i fan che mi hanno chiesto di
fare questa cagata ringraziare i ragazzi
io ti ammazzo lorenzo la passano troppo
tempo di banalissimi 3 2 1
porca [ __ ] ma no non ha ripreso
bisogna rifare il peso lascio il
telefono e uomini ma nella gamba così
[Musica]
vigenti muti m ammettendo che la ragazza
che hai brancato ti ha lanciato per
quella italia torbide interessare la
ragazza del trend dello scorso video
[Musica]
allora io ho tagliato la reaction della
ragazza per chi era e stato strano non
mi ha lanciato e successo questo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
è successo veramente e alla fine mi
seguiva è quindi niente c'è rimasto da
jean perde grazie al messaggio
probabilmente sarà lei che mi chiede di
uscire mi risponde favia una volta
rispondevi tanto i commenti ora vedo che
gli sfondi poche perché non ti frega più
niente di noi piego questa cosa anche se
dovrebbe essere più che ovvio allora
all'inizio ho iniziato a raggiungere i
traguardi tipo 10.000 iscritti ventimila
riuscivo a rispondere perché mi
arrivavano messaggi in una quantità
ancora sostenibile per poter rispondere
ancora adesso lo faccio però non siete
più in 10.000 20.000 7 siete quasi 2
milioni ragazzi quasi però siete tanti
se veramente tanti impossibile
rispondere a tutti i ragazzi in fondo
ogni tanto e solo che non si vedono le
mie risposte perché sono talmente tanti
commenti che anche le mie risposte sono
c'è poi sepolte dalla valanga di
commenti quindi ragazzi se non rispondo
a chi è impossibile rispondere a tutte
quelle volte in cui rispondo si vede
poco perché ci sono troppi commenti
comunque è normale è proprio chi non ci
arriva lo spiego non si sa mai ogni
tanto è capitato di leggere il tipo fa
20 si è montato la testa perchè non
rispondi più c'è zio l'unica volta in
cui mi sono montato la testa mia vita è
stata questa
oppure quando mi sono messo un piranha
basta anche ragazzine che posso
concludere qui video spero che vi sia
piaciuto spero che la mia gamba sexy sia
di vostro gradimento un mi piace per la
ceretta penso sia dovuto
poi vabbè come voleva è la fa a se sto
dicendo affari domanda non mi devi
rompere il cazzo ok siccome quasi estate
quindi dovrà andare anch'io magari
spiaggia se riesco qualche volta come
cazzo posso uscire in pantaloncini corti
se adesso sono conciato così
fatemi sapere ragazzi se avete un modo
per farvi crescere dei peli perché io
non ce l'ho l'idea della madonna all è
perfetto sino a tassino non si nota
perfetta quindi ragazzi io e la mia
gamba vi salutiamo quindi ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto maastricht ha lasciato
momento mi piace anche a pagine di
facebook e come ogni video tratta a
deliziare
mi piace per la polizia e non mi ha
ancora trovato cassetti non sono
riusciti scrittrici vedevano passerino
bella ragazza